misses his first bridges the rebound
paul floats it ahead to bridges and
bridges stepped out of bounds
so quick turnover for the suns
and lebron james here no doubt to cheer
on one of his
closest friends chris paul
and that wasn't chris paul's turnover by
stats but that's his turnover
leading bridges presented by youtube tv
quarterback
kyla murray courtside seat here for game
five
in phoenix vanessa hutchins who sang the
national anthem before tonight's game
clearly enjoying himself speaking of
singing
beautiful voice of adele
and the uh the star of the new space jam
movie
also here in attendance as we look at
some of the numbers from the first half
and it's all about
[Music]
uh now from the line three for six
got 29 points
perfect free throw there
ariana center his first nba finals in
here his eighth year looking for his
first title
look at some of the greats including one
here in the building lebron james
took him a while to get his first title
michael jordan in his seventh year with
his first title
james didn't get his first title since
his ninth year in the nba
one for two bridges the rebound seven
point game under five to play
who will take a 3-2 lead when this
series shifts to milwaukee